Mysteries of Vernacular.
Yankee: a New England resident or, more generally,...
...a person who lives in or is from the United States.
Though the origin of "Yankee" is uncertain, this all-American word most likely descended from...
...the Dutch moniker "Janke," a diminutive meaning "little Jan" or "little John."
In the 17th century, "Janke" was the common nickname of Dutch sailors, pirates in particular.
A Dutch pirate ship operating in the West Indies was even called the Yankey.
Over the years, "Yankee" transformed from a pirate's nickname into a general term of contempt.
In 1758, British general James Wolfe used "Yankee" as a pejorative term...
...for the colonists under his supervision.
But the insult wasn't limited to soldiers.
"Yankee" quickly came to mean "New Englander,"...
...and by the 1780s, it was used to look down upon any American.
During the Revolution, colonists co-opted "Yankee"...
...and transformed it into a mark of national honor.
The Civil War, however, intensified the derisive definition...
...when it was used by Southerners to mock members of the Union.
Today, it carries much less emotion.
Unless, of course, we're talking about baseball.